una escena de guerra así quedó la ciudad
de petrópolis en la zona montañosa del
estado de río de janeiro en brasil
las precipitaciones producto del paso de
una tormenta provocaron deslizamientos
de tierra e inundaciones que
sorprendieron a los habitantes del lugar
los equipos de rescate no han detenido
el trabajo para encontrar sobrevivientes
de la tragedia los lugares que son vis 4
bares dubai para bus los equipos
trabajan las 24 horas no van a parar las
búsquedas van a seguir a menos que los
técnicos digan que deben parar una o dos
horas dependiendo del volumen de las
lluvias pero en condiciones normales no
parada nos magna normalidad nos no sé
para nada el pasado 15 de febrero la
zona recibió en unas horas el
equivalente a las precipitaciones de un
mes en medio del dolor los lugareños
responsabilizan de lo ocurrido a las
autoridades
maestro mención que no es una zona que
no tiene captación de agua las
autoridades no vienen aquí a hacer su
parte es parte de lo que está pasando
tome esto memphis con quien aguante hace
por el momento se mantiene el estado de
alerta en el área el número de muertos
ya supere el centenar y entre ellos hay
al menos 13 menores de edad